well I've got an off earth control
bachelor in paradise alums and recently
newlyweds Chris Rondon and crystal
Nielsen reveal they are trying for a
baby this happened all right this is
breaking news person no actually I can't
he caught up with the couple at ABC's
Television Critics Association summer
press tour party at Soho House in Los
Angeles Monday night where they dished
on expanding their family fans watched
the couple find love and to get engaged
on season five of bachelor in paradise
last summer they tied the knot in Mexico
in June of 2019 and their wedding will
be featured on this season of paradise
it'll air in a few weeks so you'll
definitely want to tune in for that
beautiful classy very elegant I went
with the funny thing is I tried on 26
dresses 26 what is that like 12 hours
doesn't know Katherine Heigl 27 dresses
and they ended up choosing a dress that
was much more simple than what I thought
I was gonna do so thought I was gonna
have like a big statement piece but I'd
really just felt like throughout those
26 dresses that I just felt like I was
different personalities of me they were
coming out and it's dress and ultimately
I just wanted to feel like myself and so
I want which is something like simple
that I just felt beautiful and like me
like I was shiny so I'm excited to for
everyone to see it
oh my god almost fainted I feel like now
we were going like through the whole
ceremony because I was on such a high
but all the emotions because I was sad
are like one two smile cry and like full
what mic my family's there so it was a
lot to take in but um as soon as she
opened up the gate you'll see what
happens because it was it was a
beautiful moment so I'll never forget
for sure